President Trump's
former confidant Omarosa
now claims that Trump
knew in advance
about the Democratic e-mails
Russia hacked
during the 2016 campaign.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
It's important to remember
that any time you hear
the President or his defenders
say anything
about the Russia probe,
they don't actually care about
the details of the case or
the legal principles at stake.
Their sole motivation is
to discredit the investigation
in the minds of voters.
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani
even admitted as much on Sunday.
-Why have you decided to
literally try this case
in the court of public opinion?
Is that a deliberate strategy
on your part?
-Yeah, absolutely deliberate.
I mean,
that's where it's being tried.
Public opinion will be,
as you know, very important.
When I came into the case,
public opinion was against us.
Think of it this way --
They're our Grand Jury.
-You think the public
is your jury?
Oh, I have bad news because
you know who's your jury?
The jury.
[ Laughter ]
When you're in the court room
and the foreman says,
"We find the defendant guilty,"
you're not going to be able
to turn around and say,
"Now let's hear from you,
America.
Text 555-0100 for 'not guilty!'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
So Giuliani admitted it.
For Trump and his team, it's not
about the facts of the case.
It's about public opinion.
That's why Rudy's on TV
all the time
looking like he just saw
a spider on his toothbrush.
[ Laughter ]
That may also be why Rudy
seems so uninterested
in the actual work
of being a lawyer.
Like, you know, researching
basic legal questions
or looking over documents.
-Of course it's a crime.
No, under article 2
of the Constitution,
I'm not going to tell you
my opinion on it
because I haven't really gotten
to the conclusion
of researching it.
-Is it possible that
Robert Mueller has something
and you have no idea
what he has?
-No.
-Why?
-Because I've been
through everything.
I've talked to the President.
The President is an honest man.
The President did nothing wrong,
hasn't done anything wrong.
Throughout this, he said,
"Give them all the documents."
John Dowd will tell you this.
1.4 million documents.
We didn't even look at them.
We just gave it to him.
-You didn't even look at them?!
[ Laughter ]
You're his lawyer!
You should probably know
what you're handing over.
"We gave Mueller everything.
Trump's schedule, his e-mails,
his tax returns -- Oh, no!"
Oh, the tax returns!
Oh, Rudy,
you screwed up this time!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ohh!
Oh, Rudy!
[ Sighs ]
I'm going to brush my teeth
to clear my head.
Spider!"
[ Laughter ]
Rudy's lack of preparation
might explain
why he can't seem to settle
on one coherent argument
about what actually happened.
For example, Robert Mueller
wants to ask Trump
about his conversation
with then-FBI director
James Comey who claims
Trump told him
to drop his investigation
of ex-National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn.
Rudy keeps cycling through
different explanations
for that conversation,
sometimes in the same interview
as he did Monday
on "Fox & Friends."
-Here's what happened.
The President says, "I never
said to Flynn anything about --"
-"I never said to Comey."
-"I never said to Comey
anything about Flynn."
Comey says,
and he adds this
at the very end,
Comey says,
"He told me to see if --
if I can give him a break."
Basically.
So we have three defenses
to that.
Under article 2
of the Constitution,
you can't really question
why the President
would say something.
He has the power to say it.
Number two, what he was saying
is perfectly justifiable.
He didn't say, "You must,
you have to,
I'll fire you if you don't."
He said, "Consider it."
Number three, he never said it.
-Oh, my God!
[ Laughter ]
He's like a [bleep] magician
frantically asking,
"is this your card?
No? Okay.
How about this one?
Okay. Hold on.
There's 50 more. Okay.
Is it a red one?
Does it start with
a fo-- sev-- nine?
[ Laughter ]
Rudy clearly just makes stuff up
as he goes along,
and now he's got a new line.
He's telling people
that Mueller told him
he would wrap up the
investigation by September 1st,
although Rudy's story
doesn't sound very convincing.
-We think it should end.
-The whole investigation?
-Absolutely.
It should be terminated.
He should put out his report,
tell the American people
what he has.
Why did I say September 1st?
Because a long time ago,
two months ago
when we met with him,
he threw out September 1st
as a date that he might be able
to get the report done by.
-Hmm.
-And --
-Does he still sound like that?
-Well, we haven't talked --
he has not repeated that
since then.
But he hasn't taken it back.
-Oh, he hasn't taken it back?
You're representing the
President of the United States,
and you're handling this case
like a fifth grader playing tag.
[ Laughter ]
"You said September 1st!
No backsies!
Now pick one of these words."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But if Rudy seems unequipped --
if Rudy seems at all unequipped
to handle the Russia
investigation so far,
then he's really going to be
in over his head this week
with the latest revelations
from Trump's former confidant
and aide
Omarosa Manigault-Newman.
Omarosa's tell-all book has
a lot of sensational allegations
like her claim that she saw
Trump put a note in his mouth.
[ Laughter ]
Now this is Omarosa
we're talking about.
So anything she says should be
taken with a grain of lithium.
[ Laughter ]
But yesterday she dropped
a new bombshell
claiming that Trump
knew in advance
about the Hillary Clinton
e-mails
that Russia hacked
during the campaign.
-I think that he should come
clean with the American people.
I think that he should honest
about what he did during
the campaign and what he
continued to do
in the White House.
-You were instructed,
according to your book,
to bring up the e-mails
at every point you could
at the end of the 2016 campaign?
-That's correct.
-Hillary Clinton's e-mails.
-Yes, that was our talker.
-Did Donald Trump know about
those e-mails
before they came out?
-Absolutely.
-He knew about them?
-Yes.
-He knew what was coming out
before WikilLeaks released them?
-Yes.
-Amazing. So after Trump's
public praise of Vladimir Putin,
his attorney general's meetings
with Russians,
his campaign chairman's
money laundering,
his deputy campaign chairman's
tax fraud,
his personal fixer's
secret shell company,
his national security advisor's
lies to the FBI,
his son's attempt to get dirt
from a foreign adversary
and son-in-law's
secret back channels
with that adversary,
the person who could end up
taking down
the President
of the United States is Omarosa.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Omarosa.
It took her 14 years,
but she's finally getting
revenge for Trump firing her
in season one.
[ Laughter ]
Now, let's be honest --
the only fitting way
for this presidency to end
would be Trump to get indicted
and leave the White House
crying in the back of a cab.
[ Laughter ]
Omarosa has also written in
her book that Trump was furious
at his son Don Jr. after Don Jr.
released his e-mails
with Russians revealing that
the infamous Trump Tower meeting
in 2016 was an attempt to get
dirt on Hillary Clinton.
That contradicted
their original story
that the meeting was about
adoption policy.
Omarosa writes...
Wait, so he just said this in
passing during a conversation?
Can you imagine making small
talk with Trump in the elevator?
"Hey, Donald.
Hot enough for you?"
[ As Trump ]
"My son's an ass[bleep]"
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Now, Omarosa obviously has
as much credibility
as anyone else in Trump World,
which is to say very little.
But she's been releasing
secret tapes
of her conversations to back up
her side of the story.
In fact, she's taped everyone
from John Kelly to Ivanka Trump
to Jared Kushner
to the President himself,
which is incredible given that,
as we've noted before,
Trump has a lifelong obsession
with being secretly taped.
We saw that shortly after
he became President
when he falsely accused Obama
of tapping his wires
and then angrily tried to
storm out of an interview
when he was asked to provide
evidence for that claim.
-Did President Obama give you
any advice that was helpful?
That you think,
wow, he really --
-Well, was very nice to me.
But after that,
we've had some difficulties.
So it doesn't matter.
You know, words are less
important to me than deeds.
And you saw what happened
with surveillance.
-But you stand by that claim
about him?
-I don't stand by anything.
I just --
You can take it
the way you want.
I think that is a very big
surveillance of our citizens.
I think it's a very big topic.
And it's a topic that should
be number one
and we should find out
what the hell is going on.
I have my own opinions.
You can have your own opinions.
-But I want to know
your opinions.
You're the President
of the United States.
-Okay. That's enough.
Thank you. Thank you very much.
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Trump ]
"Now if you'll excuse me,
I have a lot of paperwork
to eat."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Trump
surrounded himself with grifters
and con artists, and now that
it's coming back to haunt him,
he's trying to grift his way
out of it.
It's the first rule of Trumpism.
Everyone is grifting
everyone else
and everyone eventually
turns on Trump.
Omarosa is just
the latest example.
They're all following
the Trump mantra which is...
-I don't stand by anything.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪